hi my name is daphna shohami i'm a
neuroscientist at columbia university
and today i've been asked to explain
memory at five levels of increasing
complexity my research aims to
understand
how memories are created and how they
shape who we are what we do and the
decisions we make
[Music]
we're here today to talk about memory
when i say the word memory what comes to
your mind like
i once went on vacation
to
the dominican republic i
think i was like
six or five years old so on your trip
what was the funnest day ever
there's this pool i love pools and then
there's just slide can go down and
there's pool noodles there too and then
there's a little tiny sandbox it's
pretty amazing right because it happened
like a year or two ago our memory is
basically a record in our brain of
something that happened in the past but
that record it created isn't perfect so
that day do you remember was the pool at
your hotel i
don't really remember
do you remember from that day
what color towel you used when you got
out of the pool i think the one i used
was a dark blue or a light blue or or
like sort of a teal when you were
telling me about the sandbox felt like
you didn't have to make that
guess that you could just see the
sandbox
in your eyes
i asked you about the towel it doesn't
come to mind immediately but you can
stop and think about it and kind of make
a good guess because there are things
you know about the world and for those
of us who study memory that's a really
strong hint as to how memory works and
so for you your memory kept all the fun
stuff and all the stuff that was
important to you but the details like
did you have to have a ticket to get in
or how you got there all these other
less interesting less exciting aspects
your brain kind of decided
i'm letting go of all that information i
think it's get older you start
forgetting things more because you have
to make space for new things which is
why i forget stuff yeah that's a great
insight basically we can't remember
everything so when you
tell us this memory of that vacation and
your brain is able to kind of play
almost this movie of a memory a moment a
day that you had in your life a while
ago where do those memories come from
i do know that there's different parts
of the brain so there's probably a part
of a brain that remembers a bunch of
stuff
the hippocampus is a part of your brain
that if you kind of took it out and
looked at it it looks a lot like a
seahorse and it plays a really important
role in creating those kind of memories
that help you
two years after your vacation share with
me
um what happened that day all these
details of that day there's another part
of the brain it's actually also
important for memory and it's called the
amygdala and it is important for keeping
all the kind of emotional processing
going from memory so memory for things
that are really scary it's going to talk
to the hippocampus now and get that
memory to be really strong why do you
think it might be important to remember
scary things let's say
you you accidentally cut yourself then
your brain makes a no and says don't get
too close to sharp things or you're
going to cut yourself again you got it
and so we don't just remember everything
and we don't remember random things we
remember the things that matter to us
the most so abigail based on our
conversation today can you tell me
what is a memory a memory
is something stored in your hippo campus
and your hippocampus is a part of your
brain it's just a big record and
sometimes you can forget parts of the
record that's not that important to you
you got it
what do you know about memory i know
when you see something you could like
kind of like picture it like in your
head you can imagine it i remember
yesterday i got like orange juice but
let's say like a year or two you might
think like oh
that day i got water you know on one
hand memory is like a record of
something that happened in the past that
we can carry with us and we can like
bring it back to mind and on the other
hand we need to be
a little bit suspicious sometimes
because we might get it wrong in what
world would that memory of the orange
juice maybe be useful let's say
you grow up in a place that don't work
juices
and then you go on vacation going
somewhere and then it might like change
how you feel about orange juice
sometimes you know
memory is
doing something much simpler but no less
important for us which is it's helping
us figure out what's good and what's bad
and if we can remember what's good and
what's bad from what we did in the past
that can help us make decisions
about what to do next time so dylan
you may be surprised to learn this but
we asked your mom what some of your
favorite candies are so you have to make
a decision between these two candies and
whichever one you pick you actually get
to take with you i wish i could just say
both but
ah
i guess i'll go with
pixie six
there you go there's your decision okay
you can take those
it took you some time there you look
like you were really working hard at
that problem
and that's interesting because actually
we know that from research that when
people have to make a decision between
two things they like equally some people
like economists think oh those are the
easiest decisions because they're both
good options but as psychologists and
neuroscientists we know it's the
opposite and one of the reasons is
because
there's no simple answer of like i know
that one's better i'm just going to go
with it and so we think that that's the
kind of decision where memory is
especially important because you have to
kind of come up with more information
exactly and then also like after it's
like
maybe like i would enjoy this more than
that and like maybe i should chose
everyone and you don't know everything
you just said is exactly what we know
from research all the thoughts running
through your mind were really a kind of
about a prediction into the future right
you're like how how will this taste if
when it's in my mouth or how will i feel
about my decision down the road you know
we think of memory as something in the
past but it's an example of how you use
your memories of these two candies to
predict what's going to happen in the
future so that you can make a decision
in the present but you did it you made
your way through that yeah um torture
and now you've got to keep the candy
am i always gonna like
choose pixie stix
or sour patch kits what's gonna like
change that we fluctuate a lot because
we use different
kinds of memory to
kind of resolve the uncertainty
basically every time but also the way
we make decisions will change because
our memories change what's interesting
about your brain as a teenager is that
we know it's actually a phase of life
where the brain is especially sensitive
to rewards to things that are
exciting and positive it's a phase of
life where those rewards whether it's
candy or your friends or whatever it is
exciting can have an especially
powerful control over the decisions you
make and the memories you create
[Music]
is there any particular memory for you
that you feel has been either kind of
influential and you're in
deciding which areas to pursue or that
you feel is sort of emblematic of what
it is to have a memory i was probably
six years old and my aunt who had stage
four ovarian cancer she battled it for
20 years she got me my first science kit
and she asked me to cure cancer and i
will never forget running into my aunt's
room and just opening up the box and
seeing that microscope it was a tiny
little blue one and the little
microscope slides and the little
pipettes and it just
that memory will never be forgotten my
whole life i've got one too i was nine
and we were at the science expo in san
francisco two scientists were dissecting
um
an eye a cow's eye and i was like that
is the coolest thing i've ever seen and
there's something about that that
carried me forward something happened so
long ago it left some long lasting trace
through neural circuits and it continues
to shape the decisions we make about
what to study and what to do just being
able to apply those memories in the
future is just so crucial in everyday
life of the humans and
the fact that we're learning how that
works and i would love to hear more
about your side of memory and the
mechanisms that you're studying so we're
interested in the idea that memory is
kind of pervasive
force that shapes all our behaviors
and we're trying to understand how
different kinds of memory are organized
and different structures of the brain
and then to understand how those
different structures work together to
orchestrate complex cognitive behaviors
like decision making or reasoning and
thinking so in your researcher you focus
more on implicit or explicit memory my
work is actually kind of pushed against
that distinction between memories that
kind of are consciously accessible
versus unconscious when you say that you
don't necessarily look at implicit and
explicit memory as anything different if
you were to take a step back
what would you define as implicit in
explicit memory the
best way to kind of think about that
distinction really goes back
historically
to one of the most important discoveries
in memory research the patient is
referred to famously as patient hm the
neurosurgeon went in and removed the
tissue that happened to be right around
the hippocampus on both the left side
and the right side of hm's brain but
then they started noticing something odd
in his behavior he was not able to
create new memories of the experiences
he had after the surgery and that led
brenda milner and her colleagues to
report that the hippocampus was very
important for memory but of one
particular kind these sort of explicit
or as we now refer to them episodic
memories but the hippocampus was not
necessary for learning skills like
mirror tracing things that you can't
necessarily articulate but you just get
better at over time and it really led to
a couple of decades or more even
of an enormous amount of very important
work that kind of kept on breaking
memory down further and further into
different types episodic and semantic as
both forms of explicit memory where
episodic refers to
memory for an event that happened like
what you did yesterday morning and
semantic refers to general knowledge
about the world implicit memories being
broken down into a bunch of different
kinds like skills or habits or
conditioning
and when i started graduate school
many of us felt
kind of the next question was really to
understand how do we now understand how
they work together
this was right around when
functional magnetic resonance imaging
started becoming a popular
tool for measuring brain activity we
could scan the entire brain and we could
ask questions about multiple brain
regions at once
and we discovered that
when we
might expect during a skill learning
task that only
the stratum might show activity that we
also saw activity in the hippocampus or
when we asked someone to form an
episodic memory that we thought might
depend only on the hippocampus
we suddenly also saw activity in the
prefrontal cortex and so the confluence
of these new ideas and questions about
how different forms of memory interact
together with the development of new
tools for studying the human mind and
brain
allowed us to kind of adjust our view of
memory systems to think of them less as
multiple completely separate independent
systems and instead to try to understand
how they really work in concert with
each other
and give rise to all kinds of behaviors
that might not fit neatly into one
category or another are the
connectivities that you're seeing using
the fmri in your studies are they
different when you look at the implicit
and explicit memories are you seeing
more activity in the striatum in
comparison to the hippocampus or the
prefrontal cortex yeah you know things
are kind of breaking down in unexpected
ways i'd say i think there's been a lot
of really
great work out of multiple labs showing
hippocampal activity
related to behaviors that don't look
anything like episodic memories but
which
might depend on episodic memories right
so for example also when you're making a
decision about how to choose between two
good options
that suddenly you might see
activity in the hippocampus related to
the choice itself others have found that
you find activity in the hippocampus not
only when people are forming memories
but also when they're imagining events
that are going to happen in the future
so it kind of forces to rethink the way
we define what the hippocampus might be
doing in a way that can account for
creating memories thinking about the
future making decisions and other kinds
of behaviors that involve
what we would refer to in the field as
relational processing
and that raise all kinds of new
questions about what memory really is
reminiscing about our early influences
that made us want to be scientists is
that you know of course we know we know
better than to think that those are
necessarily accurate memories you know
this reminds me of sort of the classic
example from literature when people talk
about memory of course is marcel
proust's
madeleine in remembrance of things past
where in the book it's this um uh taste
for the for the protagonist this taste
of the crumbs of the madeleine cookie in
the tea that bring him back to his
childhood you know seven volumes then
emerge of memories of of that childhood
digging further into earlier drafts of
proof's
novel
that initially it didn't describe a
medline at all it's very interesting to
see the imperfections of the human brain
and being able to rewrite something that
happened to you and fully believe it
yourself i think that that's one of the
coolest errors in
faults in the human brain that could
exist you know i think these
imperfections i interpret them as an
indication that the role of memory is
much less about being accurate
representation of the past and much more
about being kind of a flexible compass
into the future
[Music]
so what are you studying these days well
um i'm preparing my dissertation the
general topic is going to be
how we perceive different types of
social stimuli like different people's
faces and make judgments about them and
how
the way that we report
on what we are experiencing
tells us about what's actually going on
inside our heads what i love about what
you were describing is like if you
didn't use the word memory
we're how you were talking about kind of
perceptions and social judgments
but i think probably we'd both agree
that memory is a big part of course
right like it reminds me so much of you
know what we in the field would refer to
as statistical learning on one hand we
might have like a one-shot memory a
memory of something that we saw
yesterday like what we did or what we
ate or where we were
but a lot of our memories and our
knowledge
instead are based on many many many
experiences oh absolutely um i think
this sort of reminds me of another
project that i'm doing it's fairly easy
to get
different participants to experience
consistent negative emotions to the same
stimuli
but with positive emotions it's so much
harder to study i might not react the
same to like this
like cute cat video than someone else
and
i
definitely believe that people's memory
that they're bringing up unconsciously
when they're experiencing something to
make an emotional judgment informs
especially our experience of positive
emotion
possibly
more than negative emotion
some of those examples really remind me
also some of the questions about
kind of abnormalities in memory or
trauma or disruptions in memory and how
they also
play out in terms of not just what
people remember but what they do with
those memories right as far as the way
that my research plays into it is like
the first step in
making a judgment about what to do based
on an experience we're calling for
memory is deciding
what your emotional response was i think
what we're still kind of trying to
understand as a field is the more
kind of detailed and bigger picture of
where does this model live how does it
get updated based on experiences
why does that sometimes happen and
sometimes not there are actually people
who are born without a hippocampus they
have disruptions to episodic memories
they have trouble after this
conversation or remembering what the
conversation was about but they do have
pretty good semantic information they
have a good sense of knowledge about the
world that's interesting for two reasons
one
it shows this dissociation between the
role of the hippocampus and these two
forms of memory episodic memories and
semantic memory
but the other reason it's interesting is
that people often assume that we get to
semantic memory through episodic memory
that we encounter
one dog and then another dog and then
another dog and then we learn the
concept the semantic notion of a dog
and these people their profiles suggest
that you can learn semantic information
you can learn general knowledge about
the world even without ever having the
capacity to build those individual
memories in people with intact brains
you might use a particular process but
that if that brain region that subserves
that process is damaged that it's not
that you can't do it anymore you just
now do it a different
way it's really hard to tell people like
just don't use your memory to do this
and we just sort of have to infer and
guess at what strategies that they're
doing
if there's a particular research
question that the answers you think is
going to inform the research in your lab
and perhaps in the rest of your field
you know when i look back at
some of the work from my own lab and in
the field in general i really feel like
some of the most exciting discoveries
were not an answer to a question that
was around before but they were
discoveries that made us realize we
weren't asking the right question i
think one example of that even has to do
with the connection between memory and
decision making there was a discovery
about how the stratum response to
rewards and to learning
that just
all of a sudden
flipped the way we thought about the
role of reward and learning and memory
and may force us to realize there was
something fundamentally
connected between these processes and
that discovery just raised a whole new
set of questions that didn't exist
before yeah i guess then the trick is
we need to be designing studies that
will make us most likely to find those
sort of unexpected things which is kind
of funny it's like how do you
look for something that you don't know
what it is each project should be very
focused and rigorous and know what a
study is designed for but at the same
time we have to keep
our minds open our eyes open
for what else is happening some of the
most interesting discoveries didn't make
sense at first as someone who is
studying social phenomena i like to hear
that there you go exactly
thanks so much for coming um it's great
to see you it's been a while it has been
a while i'm really excited to be here
it'd be great to just um
start by talking about your work at the
broadest level to my mind your work has
really revolutionized the field of
cognitive neuroscience more broadly i've
been really interested in how
it past understandings of the brain have
really focused on on pinpointing exactly
what each piece of the brain does but i
think that there's also a broader
conversation happening in the brain
which is between one region and another
so it's actually the pattern of
connections between these regions that
would allow for the flow of information
but i think the tools that have become
widely available now from the physics
community and mathematics and and
computer science are under the umbrella
of of network science so that is a
science of networks a science of
understanding how um bits of a system
are interconnected with one another not
just comparing two groups of people or
two
kinds of two species but we can ask even
within a single person how does the
pattern of connectivity in my brain
change as we talk with one another how
does the information flow change i think
a lot about traffic on roadway networks
as a good example of this which is you
know we can understand where the roads
are and perhaps the roads are relatively
fixed they change over long time scales
and that's similar to the brain we
really only create
large scale connections over long time
scales but we can alter the traffic on
the roadways really easily and and
that's similar to what we do in in the
brain is that we change the way that
information is flowing to allow us to
respond um to our environment it's a
great analogy you know i remember when i
first learned of your work for me as
somebody who studies learning and memory
which
are processes that are all about rapid
updating that to me was really
mind-blowing that we can now start
asking questions about
dynamics of circuits on a time scale
that's much closer to the
time scale of human thought
than anything we had before the field is
definitely opening up in the kinds of
questions that can be asked now with
these approaches
and i think what you're pointing out is
that conceptually it's where we want it
to go anyway so there's so much
orchestration that happens
and a symphony is not a single piece
it's not a single pattern of harmony
between instruments and similar to the
brain
symphony of your brain is not a single
pattern it's a very dynamically changing
pattern in the field we often talk of
having a mental model that we use to
make predictions about what's about to
happen and really use that to mean kind
of a general understanding of what's
going on
what does that look like
in terms that come from your world of
like the configuration of a circuit i
think this is the most exciting area of
memory research right now i think which
is um how people
build and remember you know and keep
with them models of the world over long
periods of time when i think about a
mental model i think about
ideas uh potential outcomes potential
events potential actions and how they
all depend on one another so when we
predict what will happen next it would
be i'm currently sitting at this piece
of the network and i know that there are
there are these possible outcomes and so
i have to get ready for those you know
four possible outcomes but that brings
this interesting question uh to the four
i think which is how does a network
system in our mind and our brain
create
a network model of the world outside
it's almost like there's a reflection in
the structure of what's inside and the
hardware and what we're building in a
very abstract way
and i think that relates to some
interesting work that's coming out about
the hippocampus too we now think of the
hippocampus um
so much in terms of memory and but
really some of the earliest work in
neuroscience
on the hippocampus
talked about the role of the hippocampus
in spatial navigation and it really
exposed i think one of the deepest
questions in memory research at least
from the neuroscience perspectives like
well what is the connection what is the
connection between spatial processing
and memory and
um why is it that neurons in the
hippocampus when an animal is navigating
amaze why is it that there's spatial
specialization there i really do think
that
this notion of a mental model uh
generative model
is where
those where memory and space meet
that makes a lot of sense and i think
that um
it makes me you know wonder how we think
about places
in the abstract what is a cognitive
place right and what is how do we map
out the cognitive spaces that we that
our our mind moves within in the same
way or in a similar way to
the spaces that we physically walk in
but i think it opens a lot up a lot of
questions about how individuals make
their own maps right and then how
the way that they choose to make that
map will then affect the way that they
may respond in the future to a new
context or environment yeah that's
really interesting and i think it also
really speaks to the kind of pervasive
and circular role of memory right
because
the maps are dependent on memories
they're built from memories and
experiences so there's this
um kind of
dialogue
with memory creating maps maps creating
experiences phrases creating memories
affecting the maps and it really makes
me think even a
question a friend asked me recently
about moods and mental health and this
feeling of like how do some people get
kind of trapped in a
state of mind where all they can see is
a particular way forward
but then something happens in the world
that shifts them to another model which
is actually really interesting because
you can make different maps in different
physical spaces too right as you walk
into a new room you make a new map of
that room so what are the doorways
basically for for mental models and i
think that often we sort of fall into
this pattern of of thinking about memory
as as always additive that we always
just keep gathering more information and
update what we currently have we don't
as often speak about deleting pieces of
information or or perceptions or
something that we thought was a was a
useful fact but actually it's not a fact
memories as
models or models first and memory as
part of what helps build a model
starts generating new predictions
exactly of the kind you just brought up
or other ways of thinking about things
because an efficient model needs to let
go of information right i've just
heard a colleague of mine joking about
the fact that the principles of
neuroscience textbook keeps growing and
growing and that if we had enough
strength in theoretical neuroscience if
our models of neuroscience were good
enough that book should shrink back we
know that memory retrieval is
essentially construction
and so you don't need to store all those
separate memories you need to construct
them but if you have a good model let go
of all those details and just construct
them to feel as if it's a memory
but really all you're doing is using the
model to fill the details it's kind of
like the matrix you know
it's getting way out there but um but it
is a way in which if you have the right
model
it should be an efficient one i wonder
what you think what you think about um
what all this means for kind of a
redefinition of what memory is in many
ways a revision or expansion of that
notion and would you be willing to try
to help me
think about
how to define it i think it's
information um certainly that had that
is stored in the brain and that can then
affect our behavior i think getting a
behavior in there somewhere seems seems
important but also is it just a record
of the past or is it you know our
perceptions of of what happened in the
past or how we've changed uh how we
think about that past event or have we
deleted that event completely and then
gathered this higher level structure
or mental model that then allows us to
behave differently in the future so it's
more alive it's more changing it's more
i think it's bubbling out in gathering
gathering and growing and becoming more
flexible but it's also sort of bubbling
in in the sense of deleting and removing
and forgetting
um so yes i think that what we need to
add perhaps is that changeability and
the behave perhaps the behavioral
relevance of that changeability yeah
what do you think i i agree i i think
you know as you were speaking i was
thinking
the maybe the most important words were
placed there is record
the record implies an etching of
something as it was and maybe what we
need instead is that it's a model
um it's an approximation it's an
abstraction um that can help us
create
the illusion of constructing a record
but that it's the model that's the
important thing that drives the whole
thing yeah yeah i agree i think that's
perfect yeah i hope you learned
something about memory it plays a role
in shaping the changing preferences of
things we encounter in our lives
memory is fundamental to everything we
do to who we are to what we order for
breakfast to how we think about our past
to how we plan our future